by synchronizing our clocks we can
organize our time and coordinate our
activities with people around the world
now scientists have engineered bacteria
to synchronize their molecular
timekeepers in a similar fashion making
this colony of e.coli fluoresce in
unison bacteria move constantly and
divide every 20 minutes so engineering
them to act in synchrony is a huge
achievement it's a feat akin to making
all the world's traffic lights blink in
unison most living things have molecular
clocks to regulate feeding patterns
sleep and so on by studying the genetic
machinery of these natural timekeepers
scientists have been able to build
molecular clocks or oscillators in the
lab ten years ago
researchers at Princeton University
showed that their artificial oscillator
worked in individual ecoli cells now
Jeff hasty and his team have gone one
step further
synchronizing clocks in a whole colony
of e.coli to do this they exploited a
common bacterial communication system
known as quorum sensing this system
coordinates the behavior of the colony
through genes that send signals to each
other the team harnessed this quorum
sensing machinery to get their cells to
talk to each other each cell you see
here has its own internal oscillator but
it also secretes a signaling molecule to
tell its neighbors the phase of its
oscillation and as neighboring cells
pick up this signal they begin to flash
in unison the flashes are made by a
fluorescent protein which the team added
to each cells clock circuitry to make
the synchrony visible if we zoom out on
this larger colony you can see the
fluorescence spread from one end to the
other in this case the colony is too
large for every cell to act in synchrony
and instead the behavior propagates
through the colony like a Mexican wave
by getting to grips with molecular clock
design in the lab scientists hope to
learn more about complex natural
processes such as rhythmic insulin
secretion and sleep cycles another
application is to develop cell implants
that use synchronized oscillators to
deliver a dose of drug at specific time
intervals with such a system we'd no
longer need to remember to take our
medicine at the same time every day this
kind of medical application is still far
from the clinic but these flashing
bacteria show that the field of
synthetic biology is making real
progress
you